your shoes are amazing
oh well meet bowie i mean rachel
i'm a big fan of both of you oh thank
you give me your baby give me
i know it's such a creepy story i rewa i
rewatched that song in preparation it's
it's just him stealing a baby go on
it is it is a weird thing but i'm still
into it um so are there any particular
like looks from the 80s that you missed
or loved
i miss the big hair and the big shoulder
pads oh brought to you by oh yeah
absolutely i love a shoulder pad i do
too because i mean kind of the
proportions you know it works for you
yeah the big hair you know closer to god
all the way in so your your new show is
all about pop culture collections right
right so what did what got you into this
show you know i had uh i had filmed a
little pilot with my daughter and the
producer that didn't go but the
producers called me and said we've got
the show you kind of travel around
meeting people with great collections
and um i had just become a life coach
and so i'm really fascinated by people
especially really people they're kind of
on the fringe of you know living in
reality not that i know on the fringe
what do you mean
voodoo you do
so i love they're on the line they're
walking a very nice they are but they're
not i mean people often ask me are these
people hoarders and they're not because
they're very intentional and they're
they know their passion they know their
purpose and they are absolutely 100
committed to it yeah and it
99 of the time has something to do with
trying to hang on to something from
their childhood
and i think that's why it's why that you
know why we're having 80s week is why
it's on me tv we all want to have you
know a simpler pure sweeter time even if
it's just 30 minutes amen it's been a
complicated few years
so did you collect anything growing up
other than crystal balls
i weirdly can i collected snow globes so
it's all questions why this is quite app
that's amazing snowglobe's like i used
to be obsessed with those nice little
everywhere i went i would get a
different snow globe and i still have
one that my friend sent me from new york
because he saw a bunch of cool broadway
shows in 2004 and then i have a snow
globe that celebrated the year 2000 uh
that if you if you played it still plays
all langs ein and it has like a cheap
little hat and bottle of champagne in
the center
it would have been an amazing snow globe
though remember when everybody thought
it was going to die in 2000 it would
have been funny it just was like that
self-destructing
it was just an apocalyptic snow globe
and would have been it and this stopper
tipping though
because that's what happened at y2k it
did nothing i know that's everybody was
so they were like everybody was storing
rice i'm like you okay but i mean it's
just like a weird anyway and then toilet
paper when coveted i'm like really
like out of all the things you could be
collecting in case
it's the fan i mean i guess you have
twitter
yeah i was just like i don't understand
why it was toilet paper anyway i'm
letting go of it
obviously um so you're a grandmother now
so is that way more fun than being a mom
because it's just kind of it is so more
it's so much more fun for so many
reasons
i babysit my grandkids every monday yes
look at that i know echo and eisley and
echo that is so cool yeah they're cool
kids i gotta have cool kids and cool
grandkids i love it i love it yes it's
just so i always see everybody talking
about how that's like their the favorite
thing to be a grandma what do they call
you they call me coco mama
what yes yes do you give them hot cocoa
a lot no no i mean this is a family show
right yes go for it well they can't
they'll never be allowed to watch this
episode until they're teenagers because
the name coco mama came because when
their parents got engaged they got
engaged in paris so i'd taken my adult
kids we went backpacking across europe
stayed in hostels so we stopped in
amsterdam oh yes and um we stayed at a
hostel called coco mama we you know we
loved it but we went to a coffee shop
yes and um they're all adults and we
decided when in amsterdam yeah you know
well um well we did the movie
mistake and you know saw well this isn't
doing anything let's have another slice
yeah oh no oh my god oh yeah so we're
going through the streets when it hits
me and i'm thinking okay there those men
over there are going to harvest our
organs in
and everyone's on bikes riding around
you're like dodging them
no i'm stopping them because i'm saying
i'm stopping people on the street and
saying uh we're from america we just had
some space cake i am responsible for
these children i am not responsible call
an ambulance call a taxi whatever get us
to coco mama
my son my son-in-law was sobered up
enough to say
well mrs call because that's what he
called me then before they got married
i'll get you back to coco mama so two
days later we were in paris they got
engaged and i said don't call me mrs
cobble anymore you don't have to call me
mom but call you know find something
else to call me yeah and he said i'm
going to call you coco mama
because because you think that you
probably said it once but you probably
said it a billion times
[Music]